BUT FIRST, PELOSI CLAIMS THE
FACTS AGAINST PRESIDENT TRUMP
ARE UNCONTESTED AND SAYS
DEMOCRATS WILL HOLD ANOTHER
HEARING MONDAY.
SNAPPING AT A REPORTED WHEN
MAKING THE ANNOUNCEMENT.
>> I WAS RAISED IN A CATHOLIC
HOUSE, WE DON'T HATE ANYBODY.
>> AS A CATHOLIC, I RESENT YOU
USING THE WORD HATE IN A
SENTENCE THAT ADDRESSES ME.
I DON'T HATE ANYONE.
DON'T MESS WITH ME WHEN IT COMES
TO WORDS LIKE THAT.
>> Jesse: PRESIDENT TRUMP
FIRING RIGHT BACK TELLING
DEMOCRATS THAT IF THEY ARE GOING
TO IMPEACH, THEY NEED TO DO IT
FAST.
WHILE THAT IS GOING DOWN, THE
BIG THING GETTING ATTENTION IS
THIS MOMENT FROM YESTERDAY'S
HEARING.
>> THE CONSTITUTION SAYS THERE
CAN BE NO TITLE OF NOBILITY AS
OF THE PRESIDENT CAN NAME HIS
SON BARON, HE CAN'T MAKE HIM A
BARON.
>> Jesse: BLASTING THE
PROFESSOR SAYING SHE SHOULD BE
ASHAMED.
GREG, THOUGHTS, FEELINGS.
>> Greg: WHERE TO START.
AT LEAST MAKE IT INTERESTING.
THIS MAKES C-SPAN LOOK LIKE MMA.
THE ONLY EXCITEMENT I COULD GET
OUT OF THIS IS WONDERING WHY WE
ARE COVERING IT.
THIS HAS BEEN A CONTINUOUS
ORCHESTRATION FOR THREE YEARS.
WE KNEW THAT THIS IS HAPPENING,
YET WE ARE OBLIGED TO ACT LIKE
THIS IS NEWS.
LOOK, THERE ARE GAVELS.
IS IN A COURT ROOM, AND A
HEARING ROOM, THERE WERE
CAMERAS, THEY WERE APPEAR TO BE
EXPERT WITNESSES WHO HAVE
WITNESSED NOTHING YET WE MUST
TREAT THEM AS THOUGH THEY ARE
WITNESSES.
WE HAVE TO SIT THERE AND KNOW
THAT THE DEMOCRATS ARE YANKING
OUR CHAIN.
THEY ARE BASICALLY PLAYING THE
LITTLE PIANO AND WE ARE DANCING
LIKE LITTLE CHIMPS AND IT DRIVES
ME NUTS WATCHING THIS BUT THAT'S
WHY I DON'T BLAME THE DEMOCRATS.
I DON'T BLAME THEM FOR THIS
BECAUSE WE ARE JUST HELPING THEM
OUT.
THIS IS A MEDIA-INDUCED COUP.
WE DECIDED WHEN THAT WOMAN MADE
THAT JOKE, IF WE DECIDED, THE
REPUBLICANS JUST GOT UP AND
LEFT, THAT WOULD'VE BEEN GREAT
AND IF WE DECIDED TO STOP
COVERING IT, THAT WOULD'VE BEEN
AMAZING.
AND THE JOKE IS ON THE PROBLEM,
IT'S A JOKE.
THE PROBLEM IS THAT IT WAS
PLANNED, IT WAS REHEARSED, IT
WAS CHOREOGRAPHED.
SHE KNEW SHE WAS AMONG FRIENDS,
SHE KNEW SHE WAS GOING TO GET
LAUGHTER.
BY THE WAY, THESE HEARINGS NOW
ARE TRUMP RALLIES FOR THE MEDIA
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T FILL ARENAS
BUT THEY CAN FILL THOSE HEARINGS
WITH SO-CALLED EXPERTS.
THIS IS THEIR WAY AND WE GET
PLAYED BY THEIR THE NETWORKS GET
PLAYED AND WE ASSAULT OUR
VIEWERS WITH THIS.
ON BACK TO GREG'S POINT, THE
DEMOCRATS CAN'T COMPETE WITH
PROMPT, SO THEY HAVE TO PRODUCE
THIS THEATER, IMPEACHMENT IS THE
ONLY THING THAT CAN TECHNICALLY
COMPETE WITH DONALD TRUMP.
SO THEY CAN'T BEAT HIM, THEY
CAN'T COOPERATE WITH HIM BECAUSE
I DON'T WANT TO, SO THEY HAVE TO
PLAY THE IMPEACHMENT CARD AND I
DON'T THINK IT'S WORKING, I
THINK IT'S COMPLETELY BACKFIRING
THINK IT'S COMPLETELY BACKFIRIN
BACKFIRING.
>> Juan: DIDN'T GREG JUST SAY
IT IS A PREORDAINED REALITY?
THEY ARE GOING TO IMPEACH HIM.
WASN'T THAT INTERESTING.
GREG'S ARGUMENT IS THAT IT WAS
BORING TO HEAR WITNESSES AND
EXPERT SO IT IS NOT COMPLETING
WITH TRUMP THE SHOWMAN, I DON'T
THINK THAT'S THE CASE.
>> Jesse: IT IS SUCKING UP ALL
THE ENERGY IN THE ROOM.
>> Juan: THAT'S WHAT YOU JUST
SAID.
IS NOT A SET UP.
I THINK THE DEMOCRATS HAVE THE
VOTES TO IMPEACH, THAT'S WHAT
NANCY PELOSI ANNOUNCED TODAY
WHEN SHE SAID WE ARE GOING TO GO
AHEAD, THE FACTS ARE ON THEIR
SIDE.
THEY ARE UNDISPUTED.
CAN I FINISH?
I TELL YOU WHAT, MOST
FAIR-MINDED PEOPLE THINK THAT
THE FACTS ARE PRETTY CLEAR.
ONE BOX OF JOHN TURLEY WASN'T
FAIR-MINDED?
>> Juan: ON THE FOX POLL, 49%
IMPEACH AND REMOVE.
CAN I FINISH?
IT IS A FOX POLL NECK THAT SAID
60% SAID HE HELD UP MILITARY AID
IN ORDER TO GET A FAVOR, 70% SAY
WHAT HE DID WAS IMPEACHABLE.
AND YOU KNOW IT'S REALLY CRAZY?
APPARENTLY ACCORDING TO
"THE WASHINGTON POST" NOT ABLE
TO PRODUCE ANYTHING.
>> Jesse: PREDICTED HE WAS A
RUSSIAN AGENT.
>> Juan: YOU SAID WAIT FOR HIM
HIM.
>> Jesse: SCHEDULED THE
HEARING ON MONDAY THE DAY THEY
DROPPED.
>> Juan: WHERE IS YOUR BOY?
HE IS OVER IN THE UKRAINE STILL
DOING THIS AND YOU WANT TO CLOSE
YOUR EYES.
>> Jesse: JUST MAD, IT'S A
SUICIDE MISSION BECAUSE YOU ARE
NOW MOVING FROM A QUID PRO QUO
TO WHAT, BRIBERY AND ABUSE OF
POWER, WHAT IS NEXT?
>> Juan: OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE.
>> Greg: IT IS GOING TO HIT
THE DEMOCRATS BECAUSE THEY ARE
GUILTY OF ABUSE OF POWER.
>> Emily: THE MOST CONFUSING
PART OF IT IS FOR THE DEMOCRATS
SAYING THEY NEEDED ALL EVIDENCE
THAT THIS IS A DELIBERATE
PROCESS WHERE THEY CARE ABOUT A
THOROUGH FACT-FINDING SEGMENT
AND THEN AN ACTUAL ANALYSIS, WHY
THE RUSH?
MOVING UP THE PACE THAT IT
REQUIRES TO GET ALL OF THE
EVIDENCE AND ALL OF A SUDDEN,
THE DEMOCRATS DO NOT CARE AND
THEY BEGAN TESTIMONY AND THEY DO
NOT CARE ABOUT THE GRAND JURY
TESTIMONY BOTH OF WHICH THE
COURT PROCEEDINGS ARE HELPING IN
JANUARY.
ALL OF A SUDDEN, THERE IS THIS
MASSIVE RUSH.
AS AN ATTORNEY, I AM SO CONFUSED
BY THAT AND AS A CITIZEN, I
THINK IT IS THE BIGGEST HELL.
>> Greg: YOU CAN'T EVEN GET
ATTORNEYS TO AGREE ON THIS
BECAUSE THEY ARE ASKING PEOPLE
OPINIONS ABOUT SOMETHING IN
WHICH THEY HAVEN'T WITNESSED.
>> Shannon: JANUARY 3RD, BOTH
OF THOSE HEARINGS ARE GOING TO
BE HELD AT THE D.C. CIRCUIT.
BUT THEY ARE CORE ARGUMENTS AND
ARE THEY NEED THEM FOR TESTIMONY
AND THEY NEED THE DOCUMENTS FROM
HIM BECAUSE IT IS ESSENTIAL TO
THE IMPEACHMENT SO THEY ARE
MAKING THAT ARGUMENT AT THE SAME
TIME THEY ARE NOT WILLING TO
WAIT ON THE RULING AND I
ACTUALLY THINK THAT MOST
EVERYONE DISAGREES ON THE FACTS.
WHAT THEY DON'T AGREE ON OR WHAT
THE FACTS MEAN BECAUSE PEOPLE
ARE SAYING WE HAVE A TRANSCRIPT
ON THE PRESIDENT SAYS I RELEASED
IT AND I AM NOT TRYING TO HIDE
ANYTHING HERE.
THE DEMOCRATS WILL LOOK AT THAT
SAME TRANSCRIPT AND SAY THIS IS
WHY WE ARE IMPEACHING.
>> Jesse: THIS IS MUCH MORE
EXCITING.
JOE BIDEN LOST HIS COOL, LET'S
WATCH.
>> YOU ARE SELLING EXCESS JUST
LIKE HIM.
>> YOU ARE A LIAR, AND LET'S DO
PUSH-UPS TOGETHER.
LET'S RUN, DO WHATEVER YOU WANT
TO DO.
YOU SAID I SET UP MY SON TO WORK
IN AN OIL COMPANY.
HERE'S THE DEAL.
I KNEW YOU WEREN'T.
YOU ARE TOO OLD TO VOTE FOR ME.
I >> Jesse: ALL RIGHT, THAT'S
A TOUGH SITUATION AND I THINK HE
HANDLED IT.
>> Greg: I THOUGHT IT WAS
OKAY.
I KIND OF LIKE FEISTY BIDEN.
>> Jesse: THAT WASN'T SLEEPY.
>> Greg: WE ARE SEEING ANOTHER
SIDE OF HIM.
>> Jesse: WHAT DID YOU THINK?
>> Juan: I AM INTERESTED TO
SEE YOUR RESPONSE BECAUSE YOU
GUYS LOVE IT WHEN TRUMP GOES OFF
ON PEOPLE.
I THINK HE RESPONDED TO A
QUESTION ABOUT HIS SON AND HE
DID SO EMPHATICALLY AND I THINK
THAT HELPS HIS CAMPAIGN.
>> Jesse: YOU HE DID SO
PASSIONATELY.
>> Greg: AT THE SAME EVENT, HE
CALLED SOMEONE FATS AND SAID HE
WAS VICE PRESIDENT AND CALLED
ALL OF THOSE VOTERS WHO WERE IN
IOWA, SAID THEY WERE IN OHIO.
SO IN ADDITION TO ALL OF THOSE,
THAT HE RESPONDED CLEARLY OUT OF
ANGER, HE HAS TO HAVE A BETTER
ANSWER BECAUSE THOSE ANSWERS ARE
PRETTY BASIC.
HE HAS TO HAVE A MEASURED
RESPONSE WEARS YOU DO BETTER.
>> Jesse: NOT A BIG CROWD
THERE EITHER.
>> Emily: I AM WORRIED FOR
THAT GUY BECAUSE HE SAID HAD HE
BEEN IN HIGH SCHOOL WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP, HE WOULD'VE
TAKEN HIM BEHIND THE GYM AND
BEAT HIM.
A PUSH-UP CONTEST MAY BE THE
LEAST.
>> Jesse: I GOT YOU SAID IT
WAS A QUOTE, BUT I DON'T THINK
THAT'S NICE FOR SHANNON BREAM TO
USE THAT WORD.
ESPECIALLY ON "THE FIVE" WHICH
IS A CLEAN SHOW.
YOU KNOW WHAT JOE DID THAT WAS
GOOD WAS WHEN THEY ASKED HIM
ABOUT -- I DON'T KNOW WHERE THIS
WAS, BUT THEY ASKED HIM ABOUT
KAMALA HARRIS' AND DO YOU HOLD A
GRUDGE OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT
AND HE SAID I AM NOT GOOD AT
HOLDING GRUDGES WHICH IS A
REALLY NICE ANSWER, A SMART
ANSWER.
>> Shannon: HE ALSO SAID HE
MAY CONSIDER THE TICKET.
>> Greg: WE'VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT IT, SHE IS GOING TO THE
WHITE HOUSE ONE WAY OR ANOTHER.
>> Jesse: UP NEXT,
HILLARY CLINTON, EVER HEARD OF
HER?
SHE WENT ON HOWARD STERN.
WAS AMAZING.
AND OF COURSE, SHE COMPLAINED
ABOUT LOSING.
WE GOT THAT NEXT.